are you gonna see the sound of freedom
oh
no
I'm not against it
but
that's something you wait to come to a
stream yeah like I see it when it's
streaming like yeah like I don't know
that's IMAX you know I mean I don't know
if you need to be IMAX yeah I could
smell the rape this is awesome it's on
TV I got nothing else to do it's already
on let's just sit here and see if it's
good yeah go on a bike it's making money
but apparently people are like this
thing I don't know man that's the thing
if you get people it's got good reviews
though the the Rotten Tomatoes and [__]
yeah yeah but people are like buying
four tickets and then just giving away
that's part of their marketing campaign
like Hollywood doesn't want this movie
to succeed so you have to make it which
is brilliant I mean these guys are just
oh they've politicized the movie in a
great way yeah and like all the
political figures
are rewarding that
politicalization of it yeah because it
all feeds
feeds exactly if you give people a
boogeyman and make them buy some I mean
they'll buy whatever also if you can be
heroic like you're heroic for seeing
this movie yeah and continuing to
promote it and it's the perfect movie
because not only is it against the
leveling ideals it's also why is it
against levels I don't know the left
doesn't want this movie to see oh
because Jim Caviezel is a polarizing guy
and I think the director has Q Anon has
a spouse Q Anon beliefs I think the the
criticism of the movie could come from
the fact that the girl that it's based
on and again who knows I think Vice
wrote an article about this or something
there's no
from the this reporter and you know how
biased [__] Vice is but from this
report they're saying that there was
really no connection at least in the
case or from the girl mentioned in the
case between her and Tom Ballard's group
whereas in the movie it seems as if he
is the one who frees her where the girl
I guess was liberated here in New York
uh
and when she was a little bit older and
that kind of stuff then now that's not
to say that like a movie about sex
trafficking shouldn't be made and it
can't bring awareness but maybe when you
go based on a true story and there's a
lot of separation between the true story
you know you're creating an opportunity
for people to be critical yeah that's
not to say that it's a justifiable
criticism but
I'm sure in his position he's like well
we just want to shine light in the best
way possible to this horrific thing that
happens so we might have changed some
details but the point is that people
know that this kind of stuff happens all
the time we have to put a stopper to it
you know whereas the detractors are
going to say oh you lied about all this
[__] to sensationalize it so you can
look more like a hero and
age it's a it's a weird position to be
anti a movie shining a light on child
sex trafficking yeah I don't I don't
know if you ever want to play that
position I think what they're afraid of
is let's say they're assuming this guy
has Q Anon beliefs in is a q Anon guy
conspiracy theorist This lends Credence
to that conspiracy theory so even if
this is okay there will be more q and
ons The Conspiracy Theory movies made
because this is successful yeah gateway
drug I guess but like even Beyond Q Anon
if you're making conspiracy theory
movies once you get to lizard people I
think we're all going to be like no I'm
not doing that'd be like saying me too
is a gateway to like Hollywood like
anti-semitic lizard people conspiracies
like oh like Hollywood is controlled by
make that connection because I like it
I'm just saying like oh Hollywood's
controlled by like a group of people
that are trying to exploit the people
that are within it specifically women to
like degrade them in order to give them
roles and that they're not actually
trying to create the best art and then
could that lead someone to be like oh
Hollywood is full of you who runs
Hollywood oh is it Jews that run
Hollywood oh are they lizard are they
yeah I'm saying it's a slippery slope
[__] yeah which I agree with I just
don't think you could say like a movie
about child sex trafficking could lead I
agree something about uh the star
caviesel how he kind of yeah apparently
I'd have to look up his exact quote but
apparently he was at like a talk or a
conference it was like a Comic-Con type
thing and he was mentioning that the
director couldn't be there because he
was like off like he was basically like
off fighting the good fight trying to
like stop pedophiles something like that
and they're trying to stop the
pedophiles from using adrenochrome which
adrenochrome is like a big like buzzword
within like the conspiracy sex driving
community that they're basically like
terrifying children they're trying to
like drink their blood in order to like
get some type of positive effect from it
so he like used that word specifically
which I think is like now feeding into
the people that are interested in that
and is that the only thing that he said
he said something he had a history of
some yes yeah he's had some things but I
think specifically related to the movie
it was that yeah quote right so he did
the movie with
lead The Passion of the Christ Passion
of the Christ he's Jesus apparently yeah
he is Jesus that's crazy that's it JC oh
you didn't see it I saw that with Dove
yeah when we were in Santa Barbara I was
crying bawling crying we had a movie and
would have dubbed him uh he he slipped
out of there real quick
I'm surprised why didn't you see that I
would think I was like young when it
came out I was young when it came out
and then I just never got around it's
not Catholic
I think it is super Catholic I didn't
realize that the Catholics were real
just like a phony religion like it was
just like a pony
please explain yeah well I mean the real
Christians are the Orthodox Christians
right
Orthodox it just says it in the name you
know what I mean well the first church
the first church built
by
the Roman Empire
was
do you know
are you serious like that's really the
name of the church
out of Freedom out this weekend he just
won off nothing
no I'm saying I'm asking a question do
you guys know which one it was no are
you asked you guys don't know but he
should know this is a person who's
familiar with religion I'm familiar with
his God you should know the first church
built this is an Empire that spread the
religion they got nothing all right I'm
back on I'm back that's what I'm saying
like you would think you would know the
first church build right by I mean the
Empire that spread the religion around
the world right like what is it but was
that the first church that was built
after death after Christ died no of
course not but those weren't really
churches that were built right they were
doing like caves and shits watching the
people bro that's 100 100 so when it
becomes valid when it becomes real
when it becomes official by my man
Constantine where where was it obviously
Constantinople Haya Sophia the First
Church Orthodox Church became Orthodox
after the schism
no yes you guys became Catholic after
the Schism they were always Orthodox
that's what they was saying they became
Orthodox oh
you know what falls apart almost
immediately
that western part of the Roman Empire
that Catholic part you know what stuck
around for another Thousand Years
that Orthodox Christianity you know it's
still around that area right now that
Orthodox Christianity didn't change
their dates didn't move that [__] around
and who like these Goofy
who runs it God Muslims God got taken
over by Muslims bro honestly look at you
real recognized real they ain't take
over Rome
Orthodox gave into the Muslims bro they
thought yo you guys are better they
looked at the Muslims they say you guys
have the Supreme Faith whereas the Roman
Catholicism delusional they held it on
dude
Catholics did I think what the Catholics
did brilliantly is they
I think that they had adapted the
religion in a brilliant way
and because of that it might not be as
authentic
but it might be more palatable
foreign
like Vatican II diluted a lot of like
Catholic teaching there was like it had
to be in Latin like the priest would be
facing the Altar and then also the
priests like turned around it became in
English a lot of things got like diluted
so even like die hard Catholics are
probably more Orthodox than like uh yeah
than people would think I think in the
Christian or I mean I'm obviously
busting balls around Mark and Catholics
but uh and just because I learned one
new thing and I like to act like I know
[__] but uh
for example I think in the Christian
Orthodox Church only bishops uh need to
be celibate
um I think everybody else can have like
a wife even if you're like part of the
church that's a good rule y'all should
adopt that one well I think they could I
think you guys flipped that somewhat
recently what the uh the fact that the
priests need to be celibate that wasn't
always that case maybe I don't know
exactly when that got changed I think
that'll change later on now it is but I
think like that wasn't from the
beginning but what the Pope says is
essentially law for Catholics right so
Catholics now that Francis is like kind
of pro-gay are y'all okay whatever he's
whatever now it depends
the pope has to be ex-cathedral that's
like church teaching so he has to speak
like basically with all confirmation of
the Bishops for it to be church doctrine
and that's only happened like four times
in the past like 150 years again to
build a pass unanimously yeah whereas
like the priest could just be saying
while should the pope like there's been
posts that like people said that like
we're women there's been popes like had
wives and concubines and [__] so like
there's been poops that have done crazy
stuff but like the pope will basically
lead the church but it has to be with
all the Bishops approved especially back
in the day the being the pope is a
political figure you were like the head
of
like the Vatican States like so you're
also like an army General yeah the Swiss
guard on your side yeah like they was
[__] people up and [__] yeah and it
was like political moves too like I
think the if you guys heard of the
Medici family yeah I've heard I've heard
about there was like a prominent family
in Florence in the Renaissance yeah yeah
they were like big money they ran all
the art right Rockefellers of uh yeah
and bankers too but uh but they but yeah
they commissioned all that beautiful art
and everything that you see and um but
they got some medicis as popes like that
was like full infiltration of a dynastic
family Catholics were the first Jews bro
people like oh Jews run the world like
no no calories were the first ones that
were secretly running everything behind
the scenes so so that's the other thing
that's kind of fire it's like we
did for that we need that bro
she's with the whole
French like secretly behind the scenes
so did they figure out what happened I
fell off you fell off damn got my body
did they fall off or was it like so I'm
looking at this [__] like
I guess they're still Empires and the
British have an Empire but it it was
more Colonial in the Empire it's like
hey we're just gonna go over there and I
guess take your [__] I don't know
exactly how Empires were in the ottoman
age or the Roman age in my understanding
it was yo you're part of us and we're
gonna run [__] over here too and we're
gonna have our people over here as well
I I don't know exactly whereas I wonder
if the Catholic church and other
churches did like a religious have like
a religious Empire and a religious
colonization
right where it's like we don't need to
go there and run [__] and figure out
your laws and everything we'll be your
God and you'll do everything that we say
because we are God and your king will
need to [__] with us because if he don't
[__] with us then we'll turn his people
against like there was an easier way to
rule the world yeah you need theocracies
before the internet
because you need some type of like
overarching omniscient power to keep
people in check and it used to be the
monarchies yeah but even the monarchies
a lot of them were ran religiously right
like they would because they realized
that they would work together with
contain them and then King Henry's the
one that broke off and was like these
[__] weren't letting me divorce
these [__] yeah exactly Thomas More
who I'm named after oh really he was the
one that was like nah you can't do it
and he got the headed for it
yeah but it's like they you need
theocracy in order to like control
people because you can't reach all these
like far away yeah you need the fear of
God and that's why they call it the
opiate of the masses and then you need
the Internet and then once the internet
comes around you people are more
interconnected you have like radio and
[__] like that you have ways to connect
and sort of surveil people and keep
people in check in large distances so
now we can get rid of theocracy is less
important and separate churches
theocracy is a problem that's why you
look at places like China where they're
like squash religion because they're
like we don't need anybody beefing with
us we don't need you thinking you're
going to get your salvation from them
you get it from here so now they have
interesting that's why you can see the
squashing of religion right now probably
because it's like hey you're getting in
the way stop making these people do what
you say when we might need them to do
some [__] hmm yeah
but yeah what an interesting time and I
wonder if maybe the Catholic Church did
that better than anybody else where they
were like okay we have so much power and
so much control we have to make sure
that we don't abuse it to the point
where the monarchies want to remove us
from the power so we have to work with
them but at the same time that we have
to bestow the beauty of you know loving
God and and Jesus in their lives and
they need to get joy from this and
continue to do it it can't just be fear
or else the next religion that's cool
will come around and then people will
jump on that one it's like a really
interesting
God I'd love to like read something
about how they're politically navigating
this new world like how the Popes are
sitting down with their Cardinals and
going okay here we go we're spreading it
but we're doing it
not by force necessarily like back in
the Crusades but by
hope like I'm trying to think yeah
that's the drug dope just give them all
like here in the um in America there's
like a group within the conservative
party that they're like they're
outwardly saying hey we're Christian
conservatives where it's like they're
tying now like their political views
with Christ like the that's but it's
like now they're outwardly saying before
it needed to be like separation of the
church and state now they're like no no
all the things we're gonna pass is in
conjunction with our religious beliefs
that [__] is dangerous and it's supposed
to be separation of church and state
yeah
in our country but you know what's
really interesting is the conservatives
that don't subscribe to the religious
beliefs are really just what what is a a
Libertarians yeah where it's like
they're just the fiscal conservatives
and
it's just interesting to see these two
groups of conservatism
Rising
in prominence where it's like you're
just seeing what people value in their
conservatives it's like listen
we want low taxes and God we want low
taxes I don't care about God yeah we
want no taxes we want no government
interference yeah but it's interesting
to see them start to separate
and I think they're less powerful when
they're separate yeah of course yeah
dividing the party yeah because before
they were all kind of on the same page
and then a lot of people I think I think
a lot of Liberals are finding their way
to being conservative but also don't
want to they're like well I want a pay
list exactly we said well I'm liberal I
want gay people to get married I want
you to have all your rights but like
[__] taxes and so and then also they're
seeing this kind of liberal thing where
it's like yo if you don't agree with
everything we agree with and you're not
us so they're like all right cool if I'm
a conservative but I'm not that I'm not
that Christian conservative that's weird
yeah I bet so I think maybe that's why
libertarianism is rising I think they're
mainly like coming from the left what's
the what's the Democratic version of
that
I feel like we don't have a a movement
for the Democrats that is branded right
now the Liberals are if you are not
completely with us you are not us I
think there's that's the loudest voice I
would say like moderate liberals I would
say liberalism and then leftism would be
like the distinction like liberalism
basically meaning like you are I'm
tolerant leftism is I'm intolerant of
intolerance yeah
I think it's the other way like leftism
would be like uh like I'm on like for
social reform like we got to get you
know like Universal Health Care like we
gotta you know help people out like get
housing for everyone but like yeah if
you say you know like if you call
something [__] like you're not a bad
person and and like there's a lot of
comedians that would identify as like
leftist whereas like liberal and this
again this is like a debated definition
but liberal would be like hey we need
like yes Queen We need more like
diversity in Hollywood we need all this
stuff
I think those are the exact opposite a
leftist is the extreme version of me
yeah and liberal is like yeah I just
vote Democrat I'm liberal I think gay
people should be able to get married
yeah uh I don't care if you would you
know you're a drag queen or whatever the
moderate lose yeah like moderate levels
are kind of what you're describing yeah
but anytime you put IST at the end it's
kind of extreme to me fascist racist but
you know but we don't have a thing for
liberals where they brand themselves I
am a leftist or whatever I don't hear
that term like I hear
oh yeah that's probably a similar thing
80s I think Reagan was a southern
Democrat before he was a republican I
might be wrong but I know 70s 70s sorry
yeah but he was a Hollywood [__]
Democrat until he ran yeah yeah
but I think there was a term Southern
Democrat that was like sort of right the
more right of life was ever a Democrat
was he he was interesting but was that
was that as being in Hollywood
I don't know like being an actor
like I think Hassan Piper was swirling
around different definitions and left
the Democrat and Republican have changed
polls so many times in history it's just
I think Hassan Parker would consider
himself a leftist
my understanding yeah and I would say
he's pretty extreme in his leftist yeah
but mostly on like uh Financial like
fiscal policies and also like
I would say
racial
and yeah I don't think he's like so like
socially radical on those ideas like I
think like he would come on here and
like joke with us
I think he would joke yeah but I also
think that he like believes very
strongly about all those things and
there's no wiggle room on his beliefs
whatsoever
yeah maybe yeah
I'm trying to think like Sam cedar or
something like would consider himself
like a leftist I don't know Destiny
might be a leftist oh that's the guy
that went on a pbd's podcast right
Samson yeah I think so yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so and my that's about the way I
understand it like I think that I don't
think that
Hassan would be tolerant of beliefs that
even if they're like for example
someone's religious beliefs if he found
them intolerant
and that's I think leftist yeah so if
there were some Muslim beliefs or
there's some Christian beliefs that went
against some of his leftist beliefs I
think he'd be like yeah you got to
change that religion is Antiquated it's
some goofy [__] you believe in you gotta
get that the [__] out of here where I
think a liberal
if they're actually being a liberal
they'd be like yeah I don't agree with
you but I'm open to your different
lifestyle and I have to accept you for
that
I think conservatives it might have
ended up backfiring but for a long time
they could just tie themselves to
religion and then get a lot of votes
that way and swing some elections and
now I think it's becoming divided to the
point that it might fracture the party I
don't know I mean I'm talking out of my
asteroid degree but it just seems like
libertarian and Christian conservatives
are like these are different things now
very different things